so what are the principles of your
political position
um well one of the principles is that
you don't need to get into what i
believe because i think it's a very
um insidious
concept that we have to be friends with
people who agree with us or or
to discuss politics at all there's this
concept
that you know politics have to permeate
every aspect of
every person's life and you know they
have to constantly be discussed this is
something i'm completely opposed to i
think it's
it's really a horrible idea uh and it's
tribalism which i'm not
entirely opposed to at its worst uh if
you know if someone is uh if you're
having an emergency at home
you know you don't quickly run a scan oh
well i want to call this person but they
voted the wrong way or something like
that
so my political views and you're
referring to anarchism
it's simply being against politics as a
mechanism of resolving disputes
and you know everything just follows as
a consequence of that
um it's i mean i we can unpack it but
that's basically it in a nutshell
is that a typical perspective on
anarchism
uh i don't know that there is a typical
perspective there's different schools
of anarchism there's like uh i think
it's there's an anarchist lapel pins
um website and they have the
the the standard flag of anarchism is
the black flag
but there's black and red black and gold
black and pink
black and blue uh so all the different
schools of anarchism
so and they disagree very heavily
uh but it's gonna be a venn diagram yeah
i understand i mean the main reason
i wasn't necessarily trying to agree but
i'm curious i'm interested i don't
see many people saying that they're
anarchists in
2021 so what why do you find it
compelling what's interesting about it
well i think it closely
explains the what we're seeing in
politics
i think it's an effective predictor of
future
social political behavior i think it's
the only
world view that allows someone to have a
clean conscience
with what they advocate uh politically
and
i think that's just basically what it
comes down to i also want to point out
that anyone who has a radical
philosophy you know is going to come off
as either a [ __ ] or a lunatic
you know if you told me that you had a
friend who's quite tall
and i said how tall and you said you
know he's 6 10 or whatever
2.1 meters it's like okay that's pretty
tall
but if you said that they're you know 10
meters tall
or they're purple tall it's nonsensical
right
so at a certain point once an ideology
is so divorced from what is presented
as you know part of the normal
realm of discourse uh people will
automatically
you know preemptively dismiss it
although that's decreasingly the case
how do you transition from a situation
where we are now to
one where there's ever anarchy at large
by definition you can't have an
anarchist party
well sure you can they have had them in
the past i mean they could just be there
to kind of
uh gin up the works and and you know
cause
uh anarchism just means voluntary
association now anarchists are opposed
to political activity but
you can certainly say like look uh you
know i'm opposed to war but i'm going
this is a case where
it's a self-defense situation so there's
the argument to made for that with
things like voting
um i'm sorry what's the start of the
question
trying to work out how you transition
how you get there yes so anarchism isn't
a location it's a relationship
and the vast um proportion of our lives
especially in the west are anarchist uh
you and i have an anarchist relationship
there's no position possibility we're
calling the police uh if there was some
kind of even
we were somewhere together we got
violent we're still not calling the
state
if we were at a bar you know i'd get
kicked out of you to get kicked out so
this claim that all
kind of um peace and prosperity is a
function the state
is really from the anarchist perspective
akin to saying well if it wasn't for all
these exorcists we'd all be possessed
uh the norm between human beings is uh
peace uh not on a large scale because
that's a function of governments
governments give war um but we generally
tend to be more peaceful than not for
the simple reason
not because people are basically good
but because violence is expensive
because once there's violence in
a situation then other people who aren't
at all associated
you see this in bar fights like people
jump in to try to quash it
because people understand very easily
that these things tend to escalate and
then it becomes very expensive to
everyone it's asymmetrical
let's put a stop to it you know right
quick um so how do you get there well
there's certain mechanisms it's
delegitimizing the state
it's encouraging um aggression not not
violent aggression but just
interpersonal aggression and hostility
towards agents of the state
it's casting um aspersions upon
democracy and democratic process
and it's not a numbers game so you know
a lot of people think well you're never
getting a majority to agree with you but
your only
your win condition of having a majority
is based on democracy
other systems do not base their win
condition on
having majority of people agree with me
and and they once
every four years go into a ballot box
and flick a switch
it seems like at a small level an
interpersonal level
individual me and you we do have quite a
an anarchist relationship but as you say
when you scale that up
is it is it realistic that you can allow
an entire 330 million person country
to exist like that well you wouldn't
need
it's not a it wouldn't be a country at
that point but let me give you an
example of how this is already
a status quo um every country is in a
state of anarchy towards every other
country
right so if a canadian kills a an
american in mexico
i don't know what happens you don't know
what happens but we know that there's a
process put in place
so if security was private or be a
function of your cell phone instead of
your geography
you know if i attacked you on the i have
one security firm you have another one
and we're at someone else's domicile
what would the situation
be we don't know but we know it would be
resolved in advance without the consumer
having to work it out
for the simple reason that if i'm on one
phone company and you're at another
it works out and we have no idea what
happened behind the scenes if their goal
is to provide security
and you know generate profit at that
they're going to make it as
easy for the users as possible as
opposed to governments
who generate funding and generate
revenue as a function of creating
problems and creating stress
and having that as an excuse to raise
taxes and uh
seize more assets from the populace does
anarchism need capitalism
in order to facilitate that then no um
the original anarchists were violently
anti-capitalist
um and they viewed capitalism you know
in a sense more similar to what we would
call nowadays corporatism
uh and their analysis of this is spot-on
uh 2020 we saw
the systemic destruction of medium and
small businesses
that was cheered on by corporate america
both with riots and looting here in the
states
and also the cove with lockdowns it did
wonders for companies like amazon or
walmart
all the little stores here in new york
that i'm a fan of they went out of
business because they couldn't sustain
it
so what uh the original anarchist people
like emma goldman and and uh
even before her bakunin and people like
that kropotkin what they were concerned
about
is this collusion between large business
and the state and in that regard they
are spot on
that this is the worst of all uh um well
not the worst of all worlds but it's
it's pretty darn bad
and by getting rid of the state you can
get rid of that collusion
right because you're you're not going to
have a monopoly
without the government forcing everyone
to be a uh
um subscriber to that product you have
what governments do
in every industry is create barriers to
entry
for smaller companies because those
offer competition
to the large dinosaurs that have
effectively seized large parts of the
market in the past
i had only known the show last week and
he said that antifa identifies
anarcho-communists and revolutionary
marxists
how close or far is this from the purity
of a normal
anarchist um it's closer than
it's pretty darn close a lot of you know
ant caps narco capitalists
think antifa doesn't have a right to
call themselves anarchists and they
certainly do
the early anarchists were very
especially in the uk
uh the term in the uk it was synonymous
with terrorists
uh this is why the sex pistol song you
know anarchy in the uk
was so shocking because there he's
johnny rod is explicitly saying i want
to destroy passersby
it was this and they're also called
nihilists at the time
this was an ideology where we're going
to have violent revolution we're going
to
you know blow up businesses or business
people and assassinate
so there is this very long history for
better for worse
um with the black flag and that um
antifa is
it regards itself in some regards in
some senses as an heir to
does that not make it difficult to try
and get people on board with though
if the thin end of the wedge like the
front end of the funnel
is rioting and looting and violence and
black flags and black block
like that doesn't seem like a very fun
world for me to step into
i am disturbed by how
much of a recruiting tool that has now
become
um in america because
the degree to which people
have become comfortable with violence
towards
state actors and people who they regard
as opposed to them
is happening at an astronomical pace
uh when the capital was stormed a couple
of weeks ago
uh the r the protesters riders whatever
you want to call them they put up a
gallows
in front of capitol hill and i think
there is
an enormous sense especially with these
lockdowns
an enormous sense of people becoming
comfortable with the idea
of doing very bad things and i'm
extremely concerned about this
uh because violence follows its own
logic it's not the kind of thing where
you know if you just shoot the king
everything resolves itself once you
start going down that road
you no one has any idea where it's going
to end up other than
what you are guaranteed of is more
oppression more violence innocent people
being hurt
uh and it's it's really something of
enormous concern to me in the beginning
of 2021
and because there is this attempt by the
corporate media here to kind of sweep it
on the rug
and when you have a population that's
become comfortable with the idea of
violence and they're kind of ignored
a they're going to be able to do it no
one's going to see it coming
and b they're going to be encouraged to
do it because now they feel that they've
been made invisible nothing to lose
didn't you say at the very beginning
though that being averse to state actors
was part of the anarchists agenda
yeah but a verse doesn't mean like
shooting people in the head
it means contempt it means do not regard
the cops as heroes
i was on tim pool not that long ago with
alex jones and one of my favorite
british isms is
they call the cops the filth uh in fact
one of this is actually a funny story i
was on the bbc
radio like this would have been 15 years
ago
and i always thought and maybe i'm wrong
that the british are a lot
more culturally liberal than the states
that were all more fuddy-duddies here
maybe this was a misconception and the
interviewer
said oh michael you know this this blog
you have you guys take a lot of shots
the cops
and i said well it's like my dad i was i
was an immigrant from the soviet union
russia i said my dad always told me
and i said this innocently you know
because i thought this is europe they're
going to have the same perspective as
the
as a russian perspective my dad always
told me wherever you go wherever you end
up in the world the stupidest people
always the cops the guy audibly gasped
and he said michael this is a family
show and changed the subject and i was
very surprised
to see that um uh having been the case
but that's the kind of thing i'm talking
about
so carl benjamin says this and i totally
agree with him
that the british are very procedural
like if you look at the there was those
scenes at the capitol hill riots where
the rioters had broken into the capital
but as they were walking through one of
the main halls our atriums had stayed
inside of the ropes
yes um that is so british that is
precisely the sort of thing that a
british person would do
uh you know they'd they'd uh make sure i
saw a guy
the other day who was outside of a
butcher's shop this is before lockdown
and he was he had gloves on
mask on smoking gloves on mask on
smoking outside of it
very procedural in the way that we go
about things
and um perhaps that's contributed to a
little bit because obviously the police
are basically the enforcement of
the procedure right what about
so you you mentioned about the capitol
hill and and the
other rights that we've seen over the
last year do you look on that and
see it as a misuse of your particular
political ideology
oh no i think whenever you have
politicians hiding in fear
uh as the way they had the rest of us
hiding in fear in their arm locked in
our homes for a year
uh the imagery there cannot ever be
unseen uh
everyone's gonna stand there and tell
you how strong the regime is and how
powerful it is
and when you have 20 people who can just
walk into the capitol including a guy
from burning man i think literally he
was a burning man person
this demonstrates that for better for
worse
this is not a system that is going to be
able to protect you
and that is the big selling point of the
state it's that you give up your choices
and we're going to keep you safe
uh big brothers watching i know they
have that those signs unironically in
london
and it's like well they're they're lying
to you so if they can't even keep these
you know d-list barbarians out from
their you know sacred
temple they're not gonna be able to
protect you and this is gonna cause a
lot of
people to recalibrate or uh
their view of the state and the state
authorities
so you see people break into the capitol
building or
take downtown uh portland or
create a capital hill autonomous zone
how do you stop people from losing so
much faith
in society as a whole that they become
nihilistic even if they don't
necessarily subscribe to the anarchist
movement you just think oh god like i
had all of my faith in the state and
now what have i got left to
support me well that's the goal is to
have them to lose all faith in the state
now if there's people whose entire sense
of identity
was faith in the state and now they feel
lost i can't help you
you're not one of my people uh i think
both of those
positions are untenable and and kind of
sad
um but i think once you you know it's
like everyone leaving home
it's like once you realize that this is
all a sham
this is enormously liberating because
now you're either free to
or in a negative sense are forced to
confront your own destiny and confront
your own choices
um this is one of the things that drove
people crazy about
you know uh the these masks they're
being told this is giving you a sense
if you follow orders you're gonna be
safe it doesn't matter what the efficacy
is
what matters is i get to be obedient and
in turn i'm being guaranteed
that my life isn't in danger it's it's
nonsensical
um but that's where we are is there a
value of despair
that newly indoctrinated anarchists
tend to slip into there must be a point
at which you go right okay all of the
old rules are gone
and none of the new rules and the new um
freedoms
liberties that must come along with
being an anarchist have they haven't
arrived yet
well yeah but that's not exclusive to
anarchism that's the the danger of
cynicism right
once you realize you know you lied to
all your life
and it's not mistakes systemically lied
to there's the danger of getting into
this stupid catcher in the rye
mindset everyone's a phony this all
sucks i'm gonna listen to
you know the cure uh right in my diary
with fingerless gloves
so my goal
is to kind of speak to those people and
be like like slap them beside the head
metaphorically and be like you're being
silly uh this is teenage you know
nonsense and now is your opportunity to
be an adult and
make your mark on the world or just find
your bliss
[Music]